let's take let's do some examples we're
finding the we're finding sums of finite
geometric series and let's just remind
ourselves in a previous video we drive
the formula where the sum of the first n
terms is equal to our first term times 1
minus our common ratio to the nth power
all over 1 minus our common ratio so
let's apply that to this finite
geometric series right over here so what
is our first term and what is our common
ratio well and what is our n well some
of you might just be able to pick it out
by inspecting this year but for the sake
of this example let's expand this out a
little bit this is going to be equal to
2 times 3 to the 0 which is just 2 plus
2 times 3 to the first power plus 2
times 3 to the second power
I could write first power there plus 2
times 3 to the third power and we're
going to go all the way to 2 times 3 to
the 99th power so what is our first term
what is our a well a is going to be 2
and we see that in all of these terms
here so a is going to be 2 what is our
well each successive term as K increases
by 1 we're multiplying by 3 again so 3
is our common ratio so that right over
there
that is our let me make sure that we
that is a and now what is n going to be
well you might be tempted to say well
we're going up to K equals 99 maybe n is
99 but we have to realize that we're
starting at K equals 0 so there is
actually 100 terms here notice when K
equals 0 that's our first term when K
equals 1 that's our second term when K
equals 2 that's our third term when K
equals 3 that's our fourth term when K
equals 99 this is our hundredth term
100th term so what we really want to
find is S sub 100 so let's write that
down
s sub 100 for this geometric series is
going to be equal to 2 times 2 times 1
minus 3 to the hundredth power to the
the hundredth power all of that all of
that over all of that over 1 minus 3 and
we could simplify this I mean at this
point it is arithmetic that you'd be
dealing with but down here you would
have a negative 2 and so you'd have 2
minus 2 R 2 divided by negative 2 so
that is just a negative and so negative
of 1 minus 3 to the hundredth that's the
same thing this is equal to 3 to the
hundredth 3 to the hundredth power minus
1 and we're done